The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Thank you for
coming out here in the rain
and the day before a quiz, but
this is stuff we need to know.
So I'm going to be talking
about a powerful class of models
for communication channels.
We've already seen the kind of
setup that we're talking about.
And so what we're
looking to do is
model a channel
between this point xn,
I think my pointer is--
OK, there we go.
Between xn and yn
out there, so what
we refer to as the
baseband channel.
So we've got xn coming in,
various things being done
to it, and then yn coming out.
And we refer to this as
the baseband channel.
So what's happening in
here is things like--
let's see-- D to A
conversion, Digital to Analog.
And then there is
the modulation.
the physical channel.
I may not have left
enough space in this box.
But here is the demodulation
and whatever filtering,
demodulation and filtering
that happens in there.
So there is distortion--
oh, I'm sorry.
I forgot the A to D, didn't I?
So let's stick
that back in here.
We're doing all our demodulation
and filtering in discrete time,
so we have an A to D
converter here, and then
D mod and filtering.
And there is various
places here that you
can get distortion and noise.
So for instance, the physical
channel is a source of noise.
But the discrete time
operations as well,
the computational pieces
can also introduce noise.
You could have numerical noise,
because you're sounding off
numbers, and so on.
So there are various places
that noise can originate.
And there are various places
that distortion of the signal
can originate.
So in the filtering
process, for instance,
or the channel
process, you can get
phenomena that will take what
started out as a straight edge
here and cause it to now get a
little bit spread out and not
so clean at the edge.
OK, so that's what we
refer to as a distortion.
So there is all sorts
of things in here
that can account for that.
Now, when we say
baseband channel,
we're actually trying to
distinguish it from the channel
that you see after
the modulation.
So once you've
modulated, you typically
move things to some
other frequency range.
And so the actual transmission
across the physical channel
happens in some other
frequency range.
And so the word
"baseband" here is
used to distinguish the
channel that we're talking
about from that channel.
So this is what we're
going to be focusing on.
And then will later come back
to talking about the modulation
and demodulation pieces.
So last time, I introduced
a way to represent
such models just as systems
with an input and an output.
One thing I made
a point of saying
was that when we look
at a figure like this--
here is a system.
We've got some input sequence
that's actually going in
and maps to some
output sequence.
So I use this
notation with a dot
there to indicate the
entire time function.
So I've got some entire
time function here
that goes through the system and
gets mapped to some entire time
function there.
And I'm not telling
you the details
of how that mapping
happens yet, but this
is my abstract picture.
Now, in many places you'll
see people writing--
and again, I said
this last time.
But I want to remind
you, you'll see
them labeling xn going into
the system and yn coming out.
And when you see
that, you've got
to think that what
you're looking at
is just a snapshot at time n.
So this picture is what you
get in a snapshot at time n,
whereas this picture
is the picture that
refers to actually mapping the
input signal, the entire input
signal to the output signal.
OK, so these are two different
ways of representing things.
In this system, I'm not
taking the value of time n
and producing a value at time n.
I typically will need to look
at lots of values of the input
to figure out any particular
value of the output.
All right, I did mention
briefly the notion of causality.
And we'll come
back to that later.
But the rough notion is that--
or a good enough notion is that
the system is called causal
if the response at
any time depends only
on present and past inputs
and not on future inputs.
That's easy enough.
And then there were--
we were going to
specialize, actually,
to the case of linear and
time-invariant systems.
And so I want to first introduce
the notion of time invariance.
Time invariance says basically
that, if you shift the input
by a certain amount, then
the output gets just shifted
by the same amount.
But the same input-output
pair works as before.
So what you're really
trying to get at
is a time-invariant system is
one where the laws by which you
compose the values of the
input to get the output
don't change with time.
So let's see.
Let me give you an example here.
Suppose I had a system
whose input and output
were related in this fashion.
Would that, do you think,
be a time-invariant system
or a time-varying system?
I seem to have functions
of time in here.
Does that make it a
time-varying system?
Or is it perhaps time invariant?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Time invariant,
because of the law [INAUDIBLE]..
PROFESSOR: OK, so
time invariant,
because the law by which
you're composing things
to get the output
doesn't depend on time.
So the point is that these
coefficients are constant.
So because these are
constant, what you
have is actually a
time-invariant system.
So to get the
output at any time,
you're taking 1/3 of the
output of the previous time
plus twice the input
of the present time.
And that prescription holds
along the entire time axis.
So the actual value
of n doesn't matter.
But if I had here
some function of n,
if, instead of 1/3, I had
something like 1/3 to the n,
now I've got a
time-varying system,
because the law by which
I combine things actually
depends on my position
along the time axis.
So this would be time invariant.
This would be not.
So that's what this
is trying to get at.
Easy enough.
The other notion was
that of linearity.
By the way, if you
read the chapter,
you'll see some
other examples that
will help you hone your
intuition for what's
time invariant and what's not.
For linearity,
the basic idea was
that you can superpose
inputs and find
the corresponding
responses by superposition.
So if you've got the
results of two experiments,
the input in one experiment
and the output, the input
in a second experiment
and the output,
and then you take a new
experiment in which the input
is a linear combination
of the previous two ones,
the response will be the
same linear combination
of the previous two responses.
So that's the basic idea here.
So linearity means that
superposition works.
And so this is another
feature that we'll use.
And for this example on top, do
you think it's linear or not?
So what you really--
the way to think
about it is, suppose
I had an experiment A
in which my output was
y, in which I fed in xA,
some time signal, and I got
a response, some time signal.
So what that means
is that this is true.
This is what it means
to say that this
is an input-output
pair in experiment A.
And now in experiment
B, similarly, I
have yB n satisfying
this equation.
So the subscript here
just means experiment
A, experiment B. So this is an
experiment A and experiment B.
So now the question
you want to ask
yourself is, is it true that, if
I defined a new input xn to be,
let's say--
what notation did I use there?
Well, I didn't want
an A and a B, did I?
OK, if you ignore the
notation on my slides,
let's say that this is an
alpha x A plus beta x B.
OK, so here is a new
experiment in which
I'm going to use an input
that's a linear combination
of the previous two inputs with
some arbitrary weights alpha
and beta.
And the question then is, is
the corresponding combination
of the outputs in the
previous experiment,
so alpha yA n plus beta yB
n, does this x and y end pair
satisfy the same equation?
OK, so what we want to
check now is, is it true--
well, is it true
that the xn here,
the yn here will satisfy
the equation on top?
And you can see very
quickly that it will.
And the reason is
that yn here is
expressed as a linear
function of the yn minus 1
and xn minus 1.
So when you substitute
these in, you'll
find that xn defined this way
and yn defined this way will
actually satisfy that equation.
So this is what superposition
requires you to test.
So if it's true for every
possible pair of experiments
here and every pair of
weights alpha and beta
that the superposition satisfies
the equations governing
the system, then what you
have is a linear system.
What about if I had to change
this to 1/3 to the power n?
So I had a time-varying
expression of this type.
So I have a time-varying
system, do you
think this system
would still be linear?
So if you work
through it, you'll
see, for the same reason, that
superposition still works.
So if I had 1/3 to the
n there instead of 1/3,
I get a time-varying
system, but I could still
superimpose solutions.
It would be a linear
time-varying system.
Now, we don't want to
spend too much time
teasing all these apart,
because what we'll be focused on
is linear and
time-invariant systems.
And you'll actually come
quickly to recognize them.
OK, I defined last time also
a pair of special signals
which you've seen before,
the unit sample signal
which has the value 1 just at
one point and the unit step
signal.
So let me just sketch
them out for you here.
So the unit sample,
this is a signal delta n
which is an entire signal.
It's not just the
number 1 at time 0.
It's the entire signal.
That's the unit sample function.
There is another notation
that's also sometimes used,
which is delta sub 0 and dot.
So this notation is a little bit
more evocative of a function,
whereas here, you
are often tempted
to think of it as a number.
This says, what I'm
looking at is a function.
It's a unit sample function.
And the 1 is at the value 0.
So if you had
delta of n minus 3,
that would be this function
shifted from 0 to 1, 2, 3.
So the 1, value 1
would sit at time 3.
Another notation for that
would have been this.
Sometimes that
notation is useful also
in making sense of expressions
that you're looking at.
OK, so this was the
unit sample function.
And then the unit step function
steps up from 0 to 1 at time 0.
That's the unit step function.
And we also talked about the
response to these two inputs.
So you see them up there.
And now my question is, if a
unit sample signal at the input
produces the unit sample
response hn at the output
and un produces
the step response,
and if what you have is
an LTI system in here--
so it's the same LTI system
that we're talking about--
can you actually relate the two?
So the question is, can
you relate the unit sample
response and the step response?
Do I need to give you both
if I have an LTI system?
Or does it suffice
to give you one?
So here is one way
to think of that.
This, by the way, is
the same LTI system.
Maybe I should indicate
that more explicitly by,
let's say, it's a specific
system, system zero.
And with the same
system, I'm trying
to deduce the results
of another experiment.
So if we're thinking
superposition,
can you tell me how to
write the unit sample
function as a linear combination
of unit step functions,
maybe delayed unit
step functions,
scaled unit step functions?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK, would it be--
you said un minus un plus 1?
Or is it un minus 1?
n minus 1?
So what we're saying
is, take this unit step
and then subtract from it
a unit step delayed by 1.
OK, so here is u of n minus 1.
If we took the unit step
and subtracted from it
a delayed unit
step, delayed by 1,
the result will be just that
value 1 at time 0 will survive.
Everything else will cancel out.
Is that what you had in mind?
OK.
So if delta of n can be written
as that linear combination
of unit steps, can
you tell me how
to write hn in terms
of unit step responses?
We're talking about
an LTI system.
I took that out, but we're still
talking about an LTI system
here.
Somebody who hasn't
spoken maybe?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: It should just be
x of n minus s of n minus 1.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, OK.
So superposition
says that, if you've
got an input that's a
linear combination of inputs
for which you know the
results of the experiment,
then the corresponding output
is the same linear combination
of the outputs for
that experiment.
So this is going to be
sn minus s n minus 1.
So you can actually
deduce the unit sample
response, given the unit setup
response for an LTI system.
So let's see.
We've used linearity.
Have we use time invariance?
We used linearity
because we said,
here is an experiment
in which the input
is a linear
combination of inputs
that we know the responses to.
Where have we invoked
time invariance?
Anyone?
The superposition idea was part
of the definition of linearity.
Because a system is
linear, if the input is
a superposition of two
inputs for which you know
the response, then the output is
the corresponding superposition
of the responses.
That seems like I've only
used superposition there.
Have I actually use
time invariance as well?
Yeah?
Sorry?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: I've used
it in concluding
that, if I put in
u of n minus 1,
the response is s of n minus 1.
So I've used time invariance
as well as linearity
here to come up
with this statement.
OK, good.
So this is what I
have on the slide.
And you've figured
it all out already.
We've arrived at this equation.
Now, if I want to turn
it around and write sn
in terms of the unit
sample response,
I can do that as
well, except this
is analogous to integrating
a differential equation.
What we have is a
difference equation here.
And when you come
to integrate, well,
in discrete time, what
you do is summation
instead of integration.
You need to assume an initial
condition of some kind.
And so it turns
out if you assume
that, way back in the past,
the value of the step response
was 0, then you can actually
go from this description
to a description the other
way, relating the step response
to the unit sample response.
OK, so if I have a causal
system, for instance, so
the causal system,
it's got no response
until the input hits it.
So when I put a
unit step in, I'm
not going to get a
response until time 0.
And so I know at minus infinity,
the step response was 0.
And I can move
forward from there.
OK, so you can actually
relate the step response
to the unit sample
response the other way
as well here, where
the summation is
from minus infinity to the
n that you're interested in.
We'll be dealing right
through with causal systems.
If there are any deviations
from that, we'll point them out.
But basically, we'll be
dealing with causal systems.
OK, so let's-- this is an
identity we'll be wanting
to play with a bit.
So let me put it up here.
So the step response, let's
say, for a causal system
is going to be summation
from k equals minus infinity
to n h of k.
So I take all the values
of the unit sample response
up to the present time
and sum them together
to get the value of the setup
response at the present time.
OK, so let's look
at an example here.
Here is the unit sample response
of a particular LTI system.
Is this a causal system?
So this is the response
to a unit sample.
So the input was 0 everywhere
except for a value of 1 here.
And you see that the
response actually happens
subsequent to that input.
So if the response
starts at time 0
or later for an input that
started at time 0 or later,
then what you are looking
at is a causal system here,
certainly in the case of
a unit sample response.
OK, so what's the step response
going to look like, then?
Anyone want to say in words?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK, so
the step response,
if we're evaluating
it at times over here,
we're summing all the values
of hk from minus infinity
up to the present time.
So the step response is 0
here, is 0 here, is 0 here.
And then a time 3,
the step response
jumps to 1, and from
then on stays at 1.
So the step response is
just that delayed step.
And it kind of makes sense,
because the kind of system
we're talking about must
be a delayed by 3 system
here, because we put in a unit
sample input, a unit sample
function.
And what came out,
if you look at it,
was actually delta of n minus 3.
It was the unit sample
function delayed by 3 steps.
Is the height-- the height
is unchanged, right?
The height of still 1.
So this must be a delay by
3 system we're looking at.
And sure, if we put in a
unit step, we're getting--
or sorry, yeah, if we
put in the unit step,
we're going to get
a response that's
just the step delayed by 3.
I'm going-- sorry, yeah?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, maybe I'm
just a little confused here.
But why is it from
negative infinity
to n and not like from
n to positive infinity.
PROFESSOR: This is because of my
assumption assuming s of minus
infinity was 0.
So I need to have a
boundary condition
from which I start inverting.
So just to go back-- let me
just go back a second here.
Oh, where am I going?
OK, so we derived
this first expression.
If we want to turn it around,
well, sn is hn plus sn minus 1.
And then I can solve
for sn minus 1.
I can keep stepping backwards.
But at some point, I
need an actual value
so that I can close
off that expression.
And if you're talking
about a causal system,
then what you're guaranteed
is that the step--
if you're talking about
a causal linear system,
because the all-zero input
produces the all-zero output,
and it's causal,
you can actually
deduce that the step response at
time minus infinity must be 0.
The input hasn't yet arrived.
Therefore, the output must be 0.
AUDIENCE: So h of 5, does
that mean [INAUDIBLE]??
PROFESSOR: H of 5
is just a number.
It's not a function, right?
If I write something like
h of 5, it's just a number.
So it means the value of the
unit sample response at time 5.
OK, this takes a
little getting used to,
but let's do another
example here.
So here is another
unit sample response.
This is more
complicated, though.
I put in a unit sample.
And what comes out
is a response that--
well, it still starts at time 0.
So I'm talking about
a causal system.
Everything to the left is 0.
And the stakes a value 0.2
for some number of steps
and then settles to 0.
So the question then is,
what is the step response?
So if you imagine
that what you're
doing to find the step
response at any time
is summing this from minus
infinity up to that time,
you will see that
the step response
is linearized like that.
And then it settles out.
OK, so you can get
one or the other.
And there are other
examples on the slides.
I won't go through all of them.
I'm going a little
slow here, because we
miss a recitation tomorrow.
Recitations tomorrow
are office hours,
so I wanted to actually
give you a few examples.
Here is a case where the unit
sample response increases
linearly and then stops.
And so the unit step
response actually
starts to accelerate
quadratically and then stops.
This is the discrete time
version of integration
that we're looking at.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Oh,
sorry, this thing?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Ah, OK,
ignore that notation.
First of all, it's bad notation.
But these are figures
that I got from somewhere.
If I was doing it from scratch,
I wouldn't have put it in.
But I'll explain it.
That's the notation
for convolution.
I don't actually
like that notation.
OK, examples of this type--
now, here is one important
thing for you to get a feel for.
Notice in all these examples,
the unit sample response
settles down to zero
after some time.
So you hit the system with
a unit sample function
at the input.
So you hit it with a value 1
at time 0 and nothing else.
And it responds.
And it response for
a while and settles.
Now, that's not true
for all systems,
that they settle in finite time.
A typical system might
ring indefinitely,
might respond
indefinitely to a kick.
Here, are all these
examples are ones
where the system has a
transient and then settles down.
And so what you expect to
see in the step response
is there is a transient.
And then it settles down.
The difference is,
in the step response,
it settles to another value.
It doesn't come back down to 0.
So when this comes
back down to zero,
what this is settled up to is
sort of the integral of this.
It's the area under
this, but we're
talking about discrete time
functions, not continuous time
functions.
So the value that it's settled
to here is the area under this.
So the duration of a
unit sample response
gives you some feel for
how long a transient lasts.
So if you've got a channel
and you hit it with an input,
you know that the
transient will last about
as long as the unit
sample response lasts.
So the transient and the step
response shows that clearly.
You can get more elaborate
sorts of unit sample responses.
Here is one that changes sign.
And correspondingly, what you
find with the step response
is that it's not a
monotonic increase
to the final steady state.
There is actually
some oscillation
before it settles down.
But it's the same idea.
You're computing
the area under this,
if you like, but the
area goes positive,
and then slightly
negative, and so on--
well, positive and
then less positive.
And so that's what
you're seeing up there.
Now, why do we talk about
step responses so much?
Well, it turns out
that for a lot of what
we do with signaling on
communication channels,
we're signaling with signals of
this type, on-off-type signals,
or plus-minus signals, the sort
of square-wave-type signals
or rectangular-wave signals.
And these can be thought
of as combinations
of unit step functions.
You may have seen this in
recitation last time as well.
So you can take an
input of this type
and write it as a linear
combination of unit step
functions.
A unit step function
that has its step at 0,
minus 1 that has its step at 4,
plus 1 that has its step at 12,
minus 1 that has its step at 24.
So if you combine those,
if you add up all of these,
you're going to get that input.
So then it's back
to this game again.
If the input is a
linear combination
of unit steps
scaled and delayed,
then the response is going to
be the same combination of unit
steps.
So that's what the
response will look like.
So here is the step
un gives rise to sn.
Therefore, minus un minus
4 will give rise to minus s
of n minus 4, and so on.
So knowing the
step response, you
can actually say what the
response of the channel
is going to be.
All right, we've seen
this visually too.
I did an example
last time where what
went in was that square
wave and what came out
after we had done the
demodulation of the filtering
was a response that sort of had
the features of what went in,
but it was a little distorted.
So you can see that what
we're looking at here,
for instance, is the character
of the step response,
because what went
in at this point--
right now the input on
the output are at rest.
You've forgotten about
what happened before.
And now the input jumps up.
Well, the output doesn't jump
up all the way immediately.
It's got a little transient
before it settles.
So what you're
looking at is really
the step response of the
channel, where the channel
includes all these pieces.
It's everything
including the filtering.
In this particular
example, if you
go back and look
at those slides,
this was all entirely due
to the local averaging
that we were doing in
the filtering here.
But it does give you some
kind of a distortion.
OK, so the step response is
important to figuring out
the shape of the
output of a channel.
Here is another example that
has a more rounded kind of step
response, but it's
still the setup response
we're looking at.
So here is the input step.
And here is the
response to the step.
Again, there is this notation.
And I've said,
ignore this for now.
We'll explain it shortly.
OK, and once you've got the
step response at the output,
you're ready to start
thinking about how
you'll detect whether it
was a 0 or a 1 that went in.
So you might set a threshold,
pick times at which
you're going to sample.
And then you come
up with your call
of what the input is,
so 1, 0, 0, and so on.
So this seems all benign enough.
But now what if
you decide you want
to get that information
across the channel faster?
So you want to signal faster?
So what you're
going to want to do
is put that same information,
the transition from 1
to 0 to 1, 1, 1,
0, 1, and so on,
you want to squeeze that into
a shorter length of time.
So suppose this is what you
send over that same channel.
Well, now you, again, are
going to superpose the step
responses.
But what's happening
now is you've
gotten so ambitious
with how fast you
want to get the bits across
that you're not giving the step
response time to settle.
So over here, yes,
there is time.
The step response
went up and settled
because you had three
1's in a row over there.
But now you're going down
to 0 for one time instant
and then jumping
right back again.
Well, here is the flipped
over step response.
And it doesn't have time to
make it all the way down.
It's jumped up again.
OK, so if you get very
ambitious with your signaling
to try and get more
of the bits across,
you're going to start seeing
the limitations imposed
by the channel.
The channel can only
respond so fast.
And you can drive it faster.
So it's important to have
a feel for that as well.
So when the channel starts
to respond like this,
you become much more
susceptible to noise.
So for instance, if there was
a noise spike at this point,
you could well end up
with a received sample
that was above the threshold.
And then you'd wrongly
decode the 0 as a 1.
So taking account of the
channel characteristics
is important when you're
setting a signaling rate.
You might want to get
information across quickly,
but you have to take
account of the fact
that the channel
needs some time.
OK, so much for steps.
We'll come back to that later.
We can do the same kind of
thing with unit samples.
So here is-- and in fact,
the rest of the lecture,
we're going to be
talking about making up
a signal as a weighted
combination of unit sample
functions.
So take an arbitrary
signal like this.
Think of it as--
let's see, this starts with
the value of something, 0.75,
I guess, at time minus 2,
and then a value of minus 0.5
at minus 1, and so on.
So here is your input signal xn.
And I want to think
of it as made up
of a bunch of unit
sample functions.
So what are the unit
sample functions?
Well, here is one that's
centered at minus 2
but scaled by the
value that the input
signal has at time minus 2.
Here is another one
centered at minus 1,
but scaled by the value
that the input signal has
at time minus 1, and so on.
So what I'm basically doing
is decomposing the input
into a weighted combination
of unit samples.
And you can always do that.
And it looks a little magical
when you put it into notation
like this, but that's
basically all that it's saying.
So to make sense of this,
think, for instance,
of putting in an
actual number here.
So if I wanted x at
time 3, well, I'm
going to set n equals 3
on the right-hand side
and evaluate the sum.
Well, the only
value that survives
is the value for
which k equals 3.
So I'll pull out x3.
So this kind of
seems tautologous.
But it's a way to
represent a general input
as a weighted combination
of delayed unit samples.
OK, so if that was what went
in, you're in the position now
to tell me what comes out.
So I'm talking
about an LTI system.
I'm talking about an LTI system.
And the input xn is a
weighted combination
with these weights of a bunch
of unit sample functions.
Well, let's actually--
well, let me actually
write this the
other way as well.
Another way to say this is, here
is a time function going in.
It's a weighted combination
over all possible values
of k of xk times--
and this is my other
notation, remember,
for unit sample functions.
So I'm saying this is a unit--
sorry, this should
be delta sub n.
What should it be?
Yeah, OK, so this is another
way to write the same thing.
We've chosen to
write it this way.
And actually, I
find that simpler.
But if you want to be
reminded that what we're
talking about here is
an entire time function,
then this is a notation
that you might go to.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Why is the
first sum [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK, good question.
Because I'm right now allowing
my input to have values
that extend from minus
infinity to plus infinity.
So I'm taking an
arbitrary function.
If we're talking about
an experiment in which
the input starts at time 0, then
we can actually simplify these.
I'll show you that.
OK, let me actually erase
this, because I don't
want to confuse you with that.
OK, so if this is what goes in--
it's a weighted combination of
unit sample functions delayed--
what is it that must come out?
OK, so what are we working with?
We're working with the
fact that, if delta of n
goes into our system,
what comes out is hn.
So if it's a
weighted combination
of deltas that goes in,
what's the response, given
that this is an LTI system?
Someone who hasn't
spoken today, maybe?
Do you want to try? yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: The Same
weighted combination
of those responses-- so
it's going to be summation
over all k, the same weight.
So it's going to be the xk's.
But now here is the responses.
So what have we been able to do?
We've been able to write
down what the output looks
like for an arbitrary input
in terms of the unit sample
response.
If you give me the unit sample
response for an LTI system,
I can write down the general
response, the response
to a general input.
And this is what we refer to as
a convolution or a convolution
sum.
That's a convolution.
It may look mysterious.
So let's actually do it.
Let's do it step by step again.
Here is our LTI system.
If I put in a unit
sample function--
OK, so this is the unit
sample function going in--
I get some response.
And let's say this is 0.
This is 1, 2, and so on.
The response, we refer to as
the unit sample response hn.
So what is this value?
This is the value h0.
This is the value h1.
This is the value h2, and so on.
OK, what if what
goes in is actually
the value x0 at this time
and 0 everywhere else?
What's the response
in that case?
So this is just a scaled version
of the unit sample function.
Instead of 1 going in,
I'm having x0 go in.
So the response is going to be--
what do we have?
The same response?
Twice the response?
What comes out?
AUDIENCE: x0 times that.
PROFESSOR: I didn't hear.
Where did that come from?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: x0 times that.
PROFESSOR: X0 times that--
OK, so what we'll
get is x0 times h0
coming out at the
first time, and then
x0 times h1 coming out
of the second time,
and then x0 h2 at the next time.
And if I keep going, I get x0,
let's say, hn at this time,
and so on.
What happens if
now it's not that,
but it's some value x1
going in at time 1 and 0
everywhere else?
So this is starting-- this
is centered at a time 1,
not at time 0.
And it's scaled by x1.
So what is it I'm going
to see at the output?
There was a hand somewhere
there previously.
Maybe you can answer now.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: The same
graph translated 1 over
and scaled by x1.
PROFESSOR: Right, exactly.
So what's going to happen
is, nothing will happen here.
I'll get x1 h0, x1 h1, and
so on, x1 h of n minus 1.
And it keeps going.
And you keep going here as well.
You keep stringing in these.
Each one of these will fire
off a scale of the unit sample
response, but delayed
appropriately.
And so at the next time,
what you're going to get here
is x2 h of n minus 2.
And it keeps going.
And what if you're interested
in the value at time n?
OK, so you look along here.
And you've come to
the value of time n.
So it's going to be the
sum of all of these,
if your input is the sum
of all of these, right?
If your input is the sum of
all of these x's, your response
is going to be the
sum of all of these.
So what's the sum
of all of these?
Well, xk h of n minus k.
That's all there is.
There is nothing-- there
is no magic to this.
It's just invoking linearity--
that's the scaling part of it--
and time invariance, which
is the delaying part of it.
It's as simple as that.
All right, so we'll be
seeing this notation a lot.
You probably recognize
this kind of notation
from the convolutional
coder as well.
And we don't want to
keep writing these sums.
So here is the
notation that we use.
We say that x is
convolved with h.
And we are interested
in the value at time n.
So this operation of--
this summation here is referred
to as a convolution, as I said.
I'm telling you what value
of time I'm interested
and the response at.
That's the n.
So that's what this notation is.
The k here is just
a dummy index.
We're summing over the k.
It doesn't matter
what I called it.
I can call it j.
I can call it l.
It doesn't matter.
The important thing is this
n here tells me at what time
I'm looking for the response.
And that's why that's the
argument that I stick in here.
All right, so all
that's on the slides,
but we've actually
derived it ourselves here.
Now, again, some
gripes about notation--
you'll find, if you look in
most engineering textbooks,
that this would be
written xn star hn.
And I can't tell you how
much I detest that notation.
You'll never find
it in a math book.
The problem here is
that this n is being
asked to do too many things.
The n is supposed to suggest--
the xn here is
supposed to suggest
we're interested in the
whole time function.
You would have been
better off calling it
x dot, but, OK, we're
used to thinking of xn
as also denoting an
entire time function.
This h is supposed-- the h
of n is supposed to denote
an entire time function.
But the n is also supposed
to tell you at what time
you're interested
in the response.
So that index is just
doing too much work.
And it ends up being confused
and confusing notation.
So when you're in your
downstream classes from here,
if you find an
instructor using that,
make sure that you
give him or her
grief and say you really
can't make sense of that,
because this is much
cleaner notation.
This is what conveys
what's actually going on.
All right, I'm going to
skip over a few things.
I just want to suggest
some properties here.
And then we'll come back
to more of this next time.
OK, so it turns out
that convolution
has nice properties.
For instance, the
order doesn't matter.
You can write x star h here,
but it's the same as h star x.
And that just comes from making
a change of variables in here.
If I call this m, then
k is equal to n minus m.
And I get something
that looks different.
But it's really the same thing.
So this is the same as h star x.
So convolution, you
can interchange orders.
There is some
conditions on this,
but we can talk
about them later.
You can associate them.
You can group them arbitrarily.
And you can
distribute convolution
over additional functions.
So all of this
actually makes it--
this is very
powerful, because it
allows you to deal with
combinations of systems.
And I'll just give
you one example.
And then we'll quit.
So here is an example of the
kind of thing you can do.
Suppose you have an input
going into one system, LTI,
with a unit sample
response h1, and then
the output of that going into
a second system, LTI with unit
sample response h2, and then
producing an overall output yn.
Well, so how do you get y?
It's h2 convolved with w.
I've dropped the
argument n because I
want to do this just
for general values.
But w itself is h1
convolved with x.
Now, I can group
these any way I want.
So I can, because
convolution is associative,
I can put those
parentheses where I want.
So this is equal to the
expression at the end.
But that's the
same result I'd get
by putting this input into
a single LTI system whose
unit sample response was
the convolution of the two
individual ones.
So I can start to collapse two
systems into one equivalent LTI
system.
And that kind of thing
ends up being powerful.
But I can also
interchange orders.
So from here, you can go to
this, which then tells you
that, for an LTI system, if
you've got systems in cascade,
if you've got two LTI
systems in cascade, actually,
the effect on the output
is the same, whatever
order the input--
the systems are connected in.
You might ask yourself whether
the same is true if this
was linear but time varying.
And you should
hopefully find out
that, in general, for linear
but time-varying systems,
you can't do this.
So really, linearity
and time invariance
is what it takes to be
able to attain this.
OK, let's leave it
at this for now.
And we'll pick up again--
well, you pick up some in
problem set four and also
next week.